[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité au sommaire de ce
journal nous verrons avec notre
partenaire TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest 18 mois après les incendies
dévastateurs en Gironde le feu de la la
forêt d'ustin continue lentement de
brûler sous terre nos enfants sont
actuellement en vacances pour un repos
bien mérité après que l'étude PISA a
pointé certaines carences dans notre
système éducatif pourtant avec via
xitani nous irons à la rencontre de
Nicolas goobbe désigné parmi les 10
meilleurs enseignants du monde enfin qui
n'a pas un jour joué au célèbre Mario
car vous savez ce plombier né de
l'imagination de shingeru Miyamoto dé
dans de nombreux jeux vidéos il est
possible à Épinal de se mettre
réellement dans la peau du héros sauveur
de
princesse voilà près d'un an et demi
maintenant que les incendies ont ravagé
des dizaines de milliers d'hectares en
Gironde et pourtant le sol continue de
brûler à Austins en cause la présence de
linit un charbon naturel qui se consume
lentement le département de la Gironde
propriétaire des lieux a donc renforcé
sa surveillance à avec un contrôle
hebdomadaire par drone regardez ce
reportage de notre partenaire TV7 la
chaîne du groupe sud-ouest sur
place c'est dans le secteur des
demoiselles à Austins que le linite ce
charbon naturel poursuit le plus
intensément sa combustion et grignote
sans relâche le sol toutes les semaines
Fran cuto ingénieur en environnement
vient donc y faire des relevés
géothermique avec son drone nous
arrivons sur un secteur des plus chauds
voilà 108 114 120° tout de suite suite
les les compteurs s'affolent un travail
minutieux d'observation qu'il a entamé
en début d'année dernière mais dont il a
renforcer la fréquence depuis le mois de
mai il le fait toutes les semaines et
non plus tous les mois il y avait l'été
avec de forts risques incendie de fort
risque de reprise et donc on a on a
préféré renforcer le suivi le vol se
poursuit et permet d'identifier des
points chauds plus ou moins
précisément les points chauds boug je
met très très très faiblement en fait ce
sont c'est lié à des des petits
mouvements de des petits mouvements de
terrain au-dessus des foyers nous
passons sur un secteur où beaucoup
d'arbres ont été touchés lors des
incendies donc ils sont au sol il sera
difficile d'aller les retirer à court
terme le sol est très humide on voit
bien les traces d'eau au fond voilà si
il y avait des points chauds mais
aujourd'hui ils sont plus détectables
sur ce secteur la circulation dans ce
domaine de 600 hactares reste tout de
même interdite jusqu'à nouvel ordre le
départte propriétaire des lieux va même
lancer une étude expérimentale avec le
bureau de recherche géologique et
minière ils vont introduire du courant
électrique dans le sol de manière à
définir les couches qui sont sous nos
pieds et repérer la liinite qui aurait
brûlé et celle qui n'aurait pas brûlé et
les risques de de d'effondrement de
manière à ce que nous après on puisse
faire des carrottages et couper les
lignes de linique qui n'auraient pas
brûlé cette étude devrait avoir lieu au
cours du prer semestre
2024 c'est l'un des plus grands navires
du monde il y a quelques jours le
palaisroyal s'est exceptionnellement
approché des côtes marseillaises toute
proche d'ailleurs de son armateur la CMA
CGM c'est un porte-container au
dimension impressionnante qui a la
particularité de fonctionner au gaz
naturel liquéfié et pour la Provence
Rudy Daan a eu la chance de monter à
bord regardez vous l'avez peut-être
aperçu au large des côtes de Marseille
et pour cause difficile de le manquer
avec ses 400 m de long et plus de 60 de
large le palais royal le plus gros
porte-coneneur propulsé au gaz naturel
liqufié du monde là la passerelle on est
à 70 m et c'est un bateau qui est dit
23000 EVP donc c'est un équivalent de
23000 containers de 20 pieds ce qui est
quasiment parmi les plus gros du monde à
l'heure actuelle c'est en fait comme un
bateau quasiment classique la seule
problématique qu'on a en plus c'est le
GNL le GNL étant transporté en
liquide si on le secoue un petit peu il
se transforme en gaz si c'est du gaz ça
monte en pression donc en fait qu'est-ce
qu'on fait bah on adapte notre route
avec du routage météo un peu plus fin
pour essayer de limiter au maximum tous
les mouvement éviter que le liquide
bouge trop dans la cuve une cuve de
18600 m³ pour alimenter un moteur tout
aussi hors norme situé à 10 m sous le
niveau de la mer 80000 chevaux en pleine
puissance vous comptez 12 cylindres
chaque cylindre vous voyez à l'intérieur
de chaque cylindre il y a un piston
comme celui-ci qui monte et qui descend
et qui a une course de 3 m un moteur
considéré comme écologique mais qui
n'est pas encore la solution ultime au
transport maritime dès qu'une
technologie qui permet de réduire
l'empreunte environnementale est
disponible on la met en œuvre on a été
les pionniers sur le GNL sera pas
forcément ça la solution d' on pense que
c'est une solution de transition il a
encore un bel avenir au gnel et
après-demain il y aura peut-être
l'hydrogène mais là c'est c'est un vrai
challenge parce que l'hydrogène quand je
vais parler de GNL on le stock à -
161°gr hydrogène liquide il faut le
stocker à - 251°gr Le Palais Royal a
quitté le port de fosse pour reprendre
sa ronde entre l'Asie du Nord et la
Méditerranée dans les stations de ski le
logement des employer saisonniers est un
problème récurrent donnant parfois lieu
à des situations complexes à Châtel en
haute de Savoie vous allez le voir la
ville a décidé de prendre le problème en
main et de racheter un hôtel pour le
transformer en résidence destinée à ses
employés de passage regardez ce
reportage de huit Montblanc Sébastien
Germain et Hugo
guillerz c'est un geste traditionnel
mais au combien fort en symbole qui a
marqué le coup d'envoi de cette
inauguration cette fois c'est officiel
l'ancien Hôtel Des Combelles propriété
de la commune de Châtel depuis 2020 et
désormais une résidence pour saisonniers
cet établissement a été entièrement
rénové et dispose aujourd'hui de 17
appartements euh à destination du
personnel à la fois pour la saison
d'hiver et la saison d'été avec euh des
surfaces allant de de 18 à 63 m² c'est
une offre qui est certes petite par
rapport au nombre d'emplois saisonniers
qui se situent en Valé d'abondance qu'on
estime à peu près à 1500 mais en tout
cas c'est on on répond à une offre la
commune de Châtel dispose aujourd'hui de
de plus de 80 logements à l'endroit euh
je dirais du du personnel petite
particularité de ce nouveau parc de
logement situé à quelques pas des pistes
il abrite un espace de coworking qui
permettra aux habitants de
télétravailler en toute liberté la
reconfiguration de ce bâtiment aura
coûté au total un peu plus de 2 million
d'euros financé par la Ville le
département et la région la commune de
Châtel a bénéficié du plan montagne euh
lors du précédent mandat de Laurent
vquier donc en en 2018 euh la région est
d'abord intervenue lors de l'acquisition
de cette ancien hôtel par le biais de
l'établissement public foncier de Haute
Savoie et ensuite la région a à nouveau
accompagné la commune pour la
réhabilitation de ce de cet hôtel en
logement en plusieurs logements donc
aujourd'hui et bien c'est un un très
beau projet qui se concrétise cette
réhabilitation s'inscrit dans le plan
montagne de la mandature actuelle de
l'exécutif régional qui privilégie
d'orénavant la restructuration des
résidences de montagne déjà existantes
d'autres opérations similaires à des
tion des saisonniers pourrait donc avoir
lieu à
l'avenir comme souvent au moment des
fêtes les établissements hospitaliers
ont besoin de sang les appels au dons
sont nombreux mais le plus efficace
c'est l'exemple à 62 ans Jean-Luc
puusénat a effectué il y a quelques jour
un cè don de son sang cap symbolique
d'ailleurs franchi à la Maison du don de
Saint-Étienne est suivi par notre
partenaire sur place
TL7 ce mardi la maison du don de Château
creux accueillit je puzna un de ces plus
fidèles donateurs qui tendait son bras à
l'occasion de son cè don du sang j'ai 62
ans donc j'ai commencé vingtaine
d'années quand j'avais ouais 20 22 ans
et bon voilà je suis à la C cè don
aujourd'hui et tout va bien je pensais
pas au début mais bon bon j'iraai pas
200 parce que je pourrais pas il y a pas
besoin de stresser on est bien on est
tranquille on est bien reçu et après
avoir rempli le questionnaire place son
don du sang avec le sourire non j'ai
rien m'a piqué et tout j'ai pas mal il y
a rien donc pas de souci avec ça on est
bien et si l'établissement français du
centre de Saint-Étienne récolte en
moyenne 150 dons tous les jours la
collecte de répondre à un besoin
essentiel il y a effectivement une une
baisse sur cette dernière semaine des
donneurs de sang donc on a un besoin
important ce sont des donneurs qui sont
réguliers qui viennent en plus monsieur
donne ses plaquette donc il donne un peu
de tout il peut donner le plement il
peut donner les plaquettes donc ça c'est
important aussi une habitude que
Jean-Luc n'est pas prêt d'arrê pour
relever le défi de la générosité je suis
àent aujourd'hui j'ai rendez-vous au
mois prochain voyez pour mois de janvier
donc ben je continue que tout monde
fasse comme moi ça sera bien tant qu'il
y a de la vie il y a de
l'espoir voilà Nicolas gob professeur de
sciences et de vie de la terre au
collège René Cassin à hade dans l'héro
et il a récemment été parmi les 10
meilleurs professeurs du monde lors du
Prix Mondial de l'enseignement au côté
d'enseignants venus du Pakistan du Chili
du Ghana ou encore d'Afrique du Sud au
moment où l'éducation nationale tente de
redresser le niveau scolaire général je
vous propose de découvrir ce professeur
hors norme avec loï Tournier pour via
Occitanie ça se rapproche des
dépressions et ça s'éloigne des
anticyclones c'est la réponse à la
question du jour et comme tous les
jeunes profs au début j'ai commencé ma
carrière en région parisienne dans
l'Académie de créteille pendant 2 ans
après j'étais 2 ans t d' dans la cabine
Montpellier et ici c'est mon premier
poste fixe comme on dit donc c'est mon
premier poste voilà question suivante a
compte de 10 à 15 en anglais on a une
boîte à question en fait chaque
professeur qui fait partie du projet qui
s'appelle et si on apprenait ensemble
chaque professeur donc pose une question
dans la boîte à question et on réactive
comme ça les connaissances des élèves au
fur et à mesure l'idée c'est bah chaque
cours d'un prof qui fait partie du
projet on pose des petites questions et
pour éviter le phénomène d'oubli qui est
naturel c'est normal que les élèves
oublient et on s'en rend compte et du
coup en posant des questions d'autres
matières de manière plus systématique
que et de manière répétée on a
l'objectif c'est de les aider à mieux
mémoriser les notions que l'on fait
passer en classe ce que le prix met en
avant euh c'est l'innovation pédagogique
il y a aussi les les méthodes est-ce
qu'elles sont efficaces ou
pas là dans le projet on s'appuie aussi
sur les sciences cognitives donc on a
une base scientifique réelle pour aider
les élèves à mieux mémoriser ce projet
met en jeu plus de la moitié des
collègues de l'établissement donc il y a
aussi un avoir un impact sur la
communauté j'aide les collègues de ma
discipline et d'autres disciplines aussi
à progresser ça c'est l'échelle de
l'Académie et le dernier point qui a
peut-être pesé dans la balance aussi
c'est ma chaîne Youtube qui s'appelle
unux où je ben je montre mon quotidien
de classe je montre comment utiliser les
outils numériques maintenant je crois
que c'est ça serait très difficile pour
moi d'aller au lycée et je pense
vraiment qu'il y a beaucoup de choses
qui se jouent au collège plus qu'au
lycée dans le sens où je me sens très
utile au collège Deir quand il y a des
élèves en difficulté je je sais que je
peux les aider que je peux faire une
différence ils sont aussi reconnaissants
de des efforts que l'on peut faire pour
eux la façon dont il enseigne comment il
enseigne sa jotiesse sa patience tout il
m'a fait adorer les SVT il est très fort
dans son métier parce que c'est parlé
aux gens et ces cours ils sont vraiment
très instructifs donc du coup ben moi
j'aime bien vraiment la dernière minute
dernière minute c'est l'histoire de
faire le point un petit peu qu'il fasse
un pas de côté et qu'il s'observe voilà
aujourd'hui la question du jour c'était
enfin la question que je leurais posé
c'est quel était mon point fort
aujourd'hui l'idée c'est de voir qu'ils
font des choses positives aussi parce
que on se concentre beaucoup sur les
choses qui font mal ou pas assez bien et
on a c'est très compliqué de de prendre
l'habitude de dire des choses positives
aux élèves aussi on débute là-dedans
donc voilà on met en place des choses
petit à petit je suis sûr que l'année
prochaine ce sera encore mieux l'année
suivante encore mieux voilà le mouflon
de Corse a failli disparaître en 190 50
mais il fait désormais partie des
mammifères protégés depuis un arrêté
ministériel de 2019 face à la diminution
inquiétante de l'espèce le parc national
régional de Corse a mis en place un
élevage en enclos depuis 3 ans plus de
50 mouflons ont pu être relâchés dans la
nature regardez ce reportage d'Alla
Richardi pour télépaisé
regardez
alors là glad où est-ce qu'on va là ben
on va à l'enclos d'élevage des moufflons
sur la commune de coince on prend la
piste qui mène à
[Musique]
l'enclot alors en fait ils ont mis ces
mouflons en enclos donc en 2004 pour
faire un élevage parce qu'il y avait un
effondrement de la population de mouflon
sur le massif de bavil et comme il
voulait pas que l'espèce disparaisse ils
ont préféré mettre des animaux en enclos
afin de faire un élevage et de pouvoir
les relâcher par la suite en nature ça a
été un succès donc là en 3 ans on a
lâché 52 moufflons sur le massif de
Cagne alors ça c'est un mélange spécial
où il y a du poids cassé de l'orge et du
maïs donc c'est un complément
alimentaire qu'on leur donne parce que
comme ils sont dans un enclos
malheureusement ils ont pas la ressource
alimentaire
nécessaire pour vivre donc on est obligé
de leur amener un supplément c'est le
seul moment où on peut les
voir qui sont paisibles et qui portent
pas en courant et cetera j'ai un rôle
euh d'observateur euh j'influe sur la
prédation et euh voilà je regarde que
tout se passe bien mais j'ai pas de je
ne touche pas les animaux non c'est des
animaux extrêmement sauvages oui c'est
des animaux très sauvages on dirait pas
parce que c'est dans les encloss mais en
fait oui ils ont gardé l'instin sauvage
ben comme ils sont habitués déjà qu'à
une personne à partir du moment où il y
a d'autres personnes d'autres odeurs de
suite c'est la panique et on les voit
pas quoi donc après on les capture pour
les relâcher donc dans leur milieu
naturel que là par exemple il y a les
mâles qui sont séparés des femelles car
on est en période de naissance et et
comme ça on peut mieux les compter mieux
les suivre parce que c'est quand même
des animaux sauvages donc c'est très
difficile de les apercevoir ah oui c'est
une passion c'est une fierté c'est des
fois c'est un peu compliqué parce c'est
de l'animal sauvage que c'est en
extérieur et cetera mais c'est le plus
beau métier du monde
[Musique]
oui je vous propose maintenant de
découvrir une femme très atypique qui a
eu 1000 et une vie après avoir découvert
l'univers de la parfumerie à 40 ans à 88
ans Yolande Barra gère toujours un
institut de beauté à Grenoble et vient
de lancer deux parfums sous sa propre
marque pour téléGrenoble Camille Avon
nous raconte la longue route semé d'
bûche de cette femme libre regardez à 88
ans elle a vécu 100 une vie c'est dans
cet institut AG grenob que Yolande Barra
gère désormais son entreprise mais avant
d'en arriver là le chemin est long à ses
39 ans alors qu'elle est mère au foyer
elle décide de se lancer dans la
parfumerie de luxe à Modane sa ville
d'origine un domaine où elle n'avait
aucune connaissance à l'époque mais pour
Yolande ce défi ne lui fait pas peur
alors elle décide d'aller toquer chez
Dior et chez Yv SaintLaurent pour
qu'elle devienne une de leurs
revendeuses de parfum j'ai ouvert avec
Dior rit et et et Saint-Laurent et c'est
comme ça que j'ai pu ouvrir ma première
parfumerie sélective mais l'histoire
s'arrête pas là son affaire marche et on
lui propose un poste de directrice
agrenoble alors elle déménage et
commence à gérer trois affaires à elle
seul mais un événement vient tout gâcher
quand un de ses collaborateurs lui fait
signer un contrat déguisé lui permettant
de racheter tous ses instituts pour un
franc symbolique Yolande perd tout mais
ne se laisse pas abattre et elle décide
de lancer sa propre gamme de cosmétique
à son nom avec un logo qui semble pour r
Saint-Laurent trop ressemblant j'ai été
convoqué par lettre par courrier à Paris
chez y Saint-Laurent pour discuter un
petit peu de mon logo quand je sonne le
représentant vient ouvrir la porte il me
dit mais tu es arrivé toute seule je lui
dis pourquoi et ben parce qu'ils sont
tous là ils vont te ils vont te dévorer
oh ben je lui dis je suis dur à manger
hein il ouvre la porte et là dans une
grande salle toute vide le directeur
France le directeur international de
avocat et le représentant et là le F
rire me prend parce que je vois mais je
dis attends ils sont tous là les sérieux
pour une histoire pour petite histoire à
Moir au final Yolande conserve son logo
à cause du covid et de l'inflation elle
a dû trouver un moyen d'arrondir les
fins de mois alors elle a eu l'idée de
lancer son propre parfum et comme
Yolande fait toujours les choses en
grand elle en a créé deux le 88 et le
renversant un projet à l'image de cet
octogénère selon ses amis
entreprendre ce ce ce ce projet qui va
être une réussite certainement je trouve
ça fantastique ce projet de parfum c'est
une folie mais elle est capable de plein
de folies et de la folie Yolande en
déborde et compte en déborder encore un
bout de temps voilà il a été l'acolite
de donke Kong mais c'est au volant de
son kartte que Mario bien sûr est devenu
une star interplanétaire de jeux vidéo à
éepinal il est possible de se mesurer en
vrai aux bananes champignons et objets
en tout genre du célèbre jeu vidéo pour
vos TV Livia bûchel et Anne Didier ont
pris les commandes de ces cartes
électriques tout à fait inédit
[Musique]
regardez pas de Mario Luigi et consorts
en vue et pourtant on s'y croirait ici
les bananes et champignons sont
remplacés par des projections dites gobo
représentant lapin carottes et autres
images décalées qui apportent bonus
oualus immersion dans un nouveau lieu de
loisir spinalien
leidrift
[Musique]
c'est en fait entre guillemets un remake
de de Mario Kart on a voulu lier le le
réel et le virtuel donc ici logiquement
en Belgique ce genre d'activité
fonctionne mais tout en projection et
nous comme je dis on a voulu vraiment
mettre le réel pour que les gens se
retrouvent pas comme SS étaient devant
leur console faut vraiment qu'il y ait
un peu de choc d'illeurs vous voyez bien
les gens s'amusent en en fonçant dans
les barrières et tout et donc on est les
premiers en France à faire ce de ce
genre d'activité la piste est ouverte
depuis le début du mois d'octobre et
semble avoir déjà trouvé son public ce
soir-là ils étaient une vingtaine et
pour tous le drift discipline consistant
à faire glisser son véhicule tout en le
maîtrisant c'était une
première c'est très glissant
effectivement un peu dur de prendre les
marques mais on s'habitue et c'est assez
fun à force on arrive à à maîtriser le
l'enchin mais non franchement c'est à
faire c'est c'est vraiment rigolo et
pour la vitesse 20 km maximum en
fonction du niveau les tri électriques
ces tricycles équipés d'une roue de BMX
à l'avant et de deux roues de karting à
l'arrière sont pour être maîtrisé
par leurs utilisateurs et à côté de
l'aspect loisir les gérants se
projettent un peu plus loin on voudrait
que des des cours de sécurité routière
soit ben viennent ici un petit peu
pratiqué parce que franchement maîtriser
un véhicule comme ça qui glisse c'est un
bien pour plus tard pour quelqu'un qui
va conduire une voiture parmi les autres
projet la création d'une franchise pour
monter un réseau en France en attendant
pour en profiter dans les vauges compter
une vingtaine
d'euros le BMX Freestyle est maintenant
une discipline olympique à quelques mois
des Jeux de Paris je vous propose de
revenir avec tv78 sur les championnats
de France qui pour la première fois se
déroulit au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline
[Applaudissements]
regardez
le spectacle était au rendez-vous au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en ivelin
pendant 2 jours les 9 et 10 décembre les
meilleurs spécialistes de BMX Freestyle
ont réalisé des figures dans l'air
centrale de la future structure
olympique une grande première car
Raville les sportifs alors c'était
incroyable parce que Ben faire ça ici
dans un Vélodrome ben c'est fou parce
qu'il y a plein de monde autour tout ça
et c'est le centre du cyclisme français
donc c'est incroyable c'est trop bien
parce que ben il y a tous les gradin
autour la piste ben ça rassemble tout le
monde c'est c'est fou quoi c'était trop
chouette d'être ici au Vélodrome
national de sa-quanttin en yeline c'est
vraiment un spot hyper important pour
nous parce que c'est là où va y avoir la
piste cet été pendant les Jeux donc
c'était un chouette clin d'œil de
pouvoir Raider ici pour ces championnats
de France le lieu est complètement
unique c'est une vraie cathédrale du
vélo en France donc trop chouette de
Raider ici plus de 90 sportifs de toute
la France sont venus sur ce rendez-vous
les stars de la discipline ont brillé
laori Perez remporte le titre de
championne de France chez les féminines
et Anthony jejan gagne chez les les
garçons c'est un bon entraînement pour
les compétitions internationales ça me
permet un peu dans la période hivernale
de de faire de r en compétition avec des
des trixs de de haut niveau donc donc
non je suis très content au total plus
de 2000 spectateurs ont assisté à cet
événement 50 % du public venait des 12
communes de l'agglomération de 50 ans
nibline il y a un petit jeune là il a
fait une belle pro belle prestation il
il nous a fait une petite chute à la fin
mais honnêtement c'était pas mal c'était
pas mal c'était un super événement
organisé à satin indoor ça permet au
riders de se confronter les uns aux
autres dans un
environnement clos avec un super public
c'est vraiment génial une ambiance super
vraiment top les organisateurs espèrent
refaire cet événement en intérieur dans
les prochaines années le vélodrome de C
an Livine pourra à nouveau accueillir le
rendez-vous voilà le succès des parcs
d'attraction ne se dém pas non plus et
notamment à Poitier où le Futuroscope a
acquis une renommée internationale pour
la conserver le parc que se réinvente en
permanence par la création de nouveaux
espaces comme ce centre aquatique
ultraamoderne avec de nombreux emplois à
la clé regardez ce reportage de notre
partenaire TV7 sur place le Futuroscope
est un acteur engagé dans la transition
énergétique et écologique avec ecology
le parc de loisirs de la Vienne confirme
cette volonté en proposant un hôtel
responsable et respectueux de
l'environnement l'idée c'était de
retranscrire les valeurs écologiques de
la politique du parc du Futuroscope dans
un hôtel thématisé donc dans le 2uxème
hôtel thématisé du parc visite d'une des
120 lodges 27 m² pouvant accueillir de 2
à 5 personnes ces structure en bois issu
de forêt durable française ont été
assemblé sur place donc on a la chambre
parentale par là qui donne sur
notre notre plan d'eau qui nous sert
aussi à gérer toutes les EAU pluviales
du site la chambre pour enfants donc qui
est inspiré vraiment d'un esprit cabane
un site nature sur 4 hectares qui a
redonné vie à une terre en frit au loin
c'est le chantier du futur Aquascope le
parc aquatique du Futuroscope 7000 m²
tout de même bienvenue à l'accueil de
l'Aquascope donc les gens récupéreront
leur billet juste en dessous de du mur
que l'on voit ici qui sera revêtu d'une
cascade numérique qui va venir au
plafond pour rester dans l'esprit du
Futuroscope direction le hub central
d'où vont partir H8 des 10 toboggans que
contra le parc on a un départ à 9 m pour
les plus petits toboggans un départ à 12
m à 15 m et à 18,50 avec des toboggans
àou des toboggans à sensation des
toboggans familiaux on a une torpille
avec un fond qui se dérobe 3 21 c'est
parti voilà il y en aura pour tous les
goûts de part et d'autres trois salles
trois ambiances l'ambiance sensation
avec une piscine à vague cascade et j
d'au une ambiance immersion au sein d'un
cinéma aquatique le pur produit
Futuroscope donc on est dans un univers
unique au monde avec différentes
attractions donc on a un bassin
immersion qui se consomme en famille on
a des plages immergé dans laquelle il va
se passer plein de choses plein
d'interactivité avec nos visiteurs et et
on a un cinéma aquatique en partie au
fond qui va accueillir jusqu'à 100
personnes un troisème espace distraction
destiné aux enfants on a une faille en
partie centrale avec deux grandes
pateeoires pour les 0 3 4 ans et des
toboggans accessible entre 3 et 7 ans
l'Aquascope pourra accueillir 1500
personnes et jusqu'à 1700 l'été lorsque
la rivière extérieure sera ouverte pour
surveiller tout ce beau monde le
Futuroscope cherche à recruter une
cinquantaine de maètres nageurs softeur
ces derniers sont formés au CRPS de
Poitier la particularité de notre projet
c'est que on propose de recruter et
former l'ensemble des collaborateurs sur
ces métiers là en janvier puis février
il y a deux sessions de formation sur la
partie softur aquatique et il reste
quelques places pour notre deè session
de formation du 23 décembre au 7 janvier
le Futuroscope rev ses habits de Noël
pour proposer à ses visiteurs une offre
féérique pour toute la
famille voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi on trouve
très vite pour une nouvelle édition je
vous souhaite bien sûr d'excellentes
fêtes de fin d'année au revoir à
[Musique]
tous